I mean what's up how are you good how
are you doing good are you just are you
just popping oh okay you've been into
the whole time I was gonna ask did you
catch the whole thing or are you just
drop it in now like wait I got to do it
do I have do I have some explaining to
do or or what are you coming to
really what's what's going on in the
comments I'm a bit scared to say
something but no I mean I I also can't
put too much input on the Barbie movie
because I haven't seen it yet I'm seeing
it on Thursday so I don't want to say
something that you know
fair enough are they not you know get
with was there anything that I've said
maybe like as a general sentiment that
you might disagree with or agree with or
anything like that or
since there's a yes in there
yeah uh just the
definition of feminism and people and I
say people because men women and anyone
in between could be a feminist
um
the actual definition of feminism is the
equality of the Sexes which is I'm a
feminist for that reason exactly like I
believe
men and women are equal men are not
Superior women are not Superior I
believe if we do the same job we should
get paid equally things like that
um but I will say in this day and age
and social media feminism is taken one
way or another and it's been uh
unfortunately looked at as more of your
feminists you're a man-hater and that's
not the case and I kind of hate that
that's like the tagline because when I
am a feminist that's immediately what
people think and it's like no I just
think you and me are the same and
there's nothing wrong with that well I
guess I guess a couple of questions for
one like when you say men and women are
equal like what exactly do you mean
because I mean can we agree that can we
agree that men and women are
fundamentally different like at their
core
yeah they're different but when it comes
to things like working a job and and not
being paid equally I think is if we're
making if we're doing the exact same job
same amount of effort work ethic is put
in like there should be no reason why
I'm making less than you are and if it
was rolls reverse I'm sure that men
would be just as upset if a woman was
making more than them
there are a couple Industries where
that's a thing I mean you look at the
modeling industry and male models don't
even touch what female models make I
mean I I guess my question though like
the reason I ask about
fundamentally different is because
would you say there are things that men
are generally better at than women in
things that women are generally better
at than men just from a biological
standpoint
yeah we all have our you know strengths
and weaknesses I'll say and I know that
you know Taylor's oldest time is uh
basically what men are the hunters and
women are basically the gatherers and
I get it but you know I just feel like
there's no reason that we shouldn't be
seen as
as equal
to certain things I mean I'll give you
credit where credit is due
and we asked for the same as a woman I
would ask for the same but some men
don't feel that way
I guess when you're talking about jobs
like I think I think one of the things
that frustrates me about the
conversation around equality is that
when
when I see like a woman on LinkedIn or
or any social media that's saying
something like Hey listen you know women
only represent
10 of the CEO positions in the Fortune
500 this needs to change we need
equality we need to be represented
equally
and it's all for the name of equality
through the reason I take an issue with
that is because
it's it's whatever I whenever I hear
those kinds of
outward statements it's all because it's
all for high status high paying jobs
it's boardroom it's Finance it's law
it's government it's politics it's
Fortune 500 but you don't you don't ever
hear those same
cries for equality when
you're talking about
trash pickup or oil drillers or coal
miners or I mean other jobs that are
extremely you know male dominated
and so because if we if we talk about we
just want equality then we should strive
for equality across all professions and
small areas but but it's not happening
so I mean but it's so
do you find that a little bit
hypocritical where it's if we want
equality how come we're only talking
about
Fortune 500 positions and CEO jobs and
Boards of Direction things like that why
aren't why aren't we
seeing just as much of a push for these
other world otherwise male-dominated
jobs
completely agree with that I think it's
it's sloyment I'm in media myself and I
mean
given you know me too and all that
obviously it's got its own issues and
whatnot but um I understand what you're
saying yeah when it comes to stuff
that's more male dominated we're not as
vocal about it or it's not just put out
there as much which again is the problem
with the whole like a quality issue and
that's why I think that it's so heavily
seen as like well women hate men or you
know like because it's like you're only
going for these jobs so you're only
going for this I I can't speak again I
never speak on stuff that I don't why do
you think that is though
but like if you had to guess why do you
think that is why do you think we're not
seeing the same push for
bricklayer jobs as we are for CEO jobs
yeah that's a that's a great question I
assume it's because that's what women
are
not but it's not woman dominated
realistically it's just not so they're
not really competing competing against
men or you know pushing that glass
ceiling whereas in other jobs I guess
like being a lawyer or being a CEO it's
it's much harder like I said I don't
work in those fields so I don't like to
speak on things that you know
the point that I'm trying to get at is
that I don't I don't quite see it as an
equality problem because I I think the
the reason that you don't see women
rushing to be bricklayers and work on
oil rigs and pick up trash is because
they're generally seen as very labor
intensive and lower status jobs whereas
CEO positions or positions in government
are seen as well-paying high status jobs
and so my my kind of answer to this is
kind of call B I throw I throw the BS
flag on the equality I I say like I
think it's perfectly fine to say no like
we want this job because it's high
status and it's high paying and it's a
highly sought after job and everybody
wants this job and I that's totally cool
I buy that
but then to sit there and say I'm not
saying you but I think there are a lot
of women out there that preach this and
to sit there and say that
I deserve to have this job simply
because I am a woman and I'm
underrepresented so I need to have more
stock given to me or I need to have more
points or I need to my I should carry
more weight in my application
because there aren't as many women well
no I would say that I would pull the BS
card on that too that goes either way
anyone can say that I'd say it's mainly
because I'm assuming and I hate to
assume because it makes NASA to you and
me
um these are women who are fighting for
these jobs because they've put in the
time the effort the studies to be in
that same position I would be the same
way if I was a lawyer if I was a doctor
if I was someone that was you know
pushing to be CEO and I put in all my
years you know I've got all my degrees
and I've done all this and I'm not
getting the recognition I would also
feel a certain way whereas if you just
if you're just saying hey women aren't
represented here so I feel like I should
be here absolutely not that can go
either way to men or women I would hate
if a man told me the same thing hey I
should have your job because you know
what there's not a lot of guys that are
doing event planning like so why can't I
have what you have absolutely I'd be
like well yeah but here's my background
and this is why I deserve one at the
position I do hold
where are your credentials if you have
the credentials to meet up to that I
think that it's a fair argument to say
why not me and that goes in both ways
whether it's a guy a girl anything
yeah like I buy that because I think
that's that gets to the root of what I'm
talking about where it's if we
keep it was a merit-based system
it becomes Merit you've got to earn it
and look you could have great
credentials and you could have the job
experience to back it up or you could
have the mahogany degrees and you still
might not get that but I don't see I
don't see a lot of of feminists with
this sort of attitude that are saying
like well I worked hard and I tried my
best but I didn't get it and that's okay
because it's a meritocracy I don't like
we don't have a lot of men that are
saying well I want to be in this job
because it's so female dominated that I
deserve to have it but there are a lot
of you know people from the feminism
angle that are saying that so I mean
look like I we don't I think we agree
more than we disagree but I guess my
question is this too like in your
opinion then if if feminism is simply
the belief that men and women are
deserve equal
treatment and I mean again we can get
into like equal means and can two beings
that are fundamentally different
biologically ever be completely equal
because I mean we see inequalities all
the time and you talk about the
experience of man and experience of
women like
is it equal that men have to wait
outside and long lines to get into bars
and clubs or pay cover and that women
get in for free is it I mean
I love that because I constantly have
this argument with my friends all the
time
um I'm a girl that goes to Miami a lot
and not the stereotypical mic
red flags in the chat I know red flags
in the chat
um and I think that that is one of my
biggest things I recently was there like
three weeks ago with my best friend
who's a guy and it was the most
frustrating thing because I'm like okay
I can get in I can get in cheaper with a
promoter or whatever and I messaged him
like hey can I come with my guy friend
they're like oh no guys sorry or yeah
for him it's a hundred bucks to get in
or this and I think that's absolutely
ridiculous because again it might be the
feminism in me being like it should be
equal but like I think like that is
ridiculous like I think again it goes
both ways if I can get in for free why
can't he
he's just as good looking as I am and at
the end of the day that's what it comes
down to for places like that and it's
just like I I listen I'm on your side
when it comes to that yes it should be
equal and all around jobs and down says
something as stupid as like getting into
Club live in Miami
100 percent
but
we live in reality and things are the
way they are versus the way that they
should be so it's like
I think we can wax poetic all day about
well things should be like this but I
think we're probably better off by
saying this is the way the world
actually works and this is what you can
do to succeed as best you can I want to
say something really I want to Pivot to
something and then I won't keep you too
long because we got a couple guys
waiting but you said
um you said um your guy best friend
oh dear here we go yeah so can you can
you elaborate a little more by what you
mean like you have a guy best friend you
have multiple guys like who is this guy
like what you know what's what's the
story here because I'm I'm a believer
that men and women generally under
unless it's under very extreme
circumstances cannot and are not friends
why are we not friends right now
well this is business to me this is a so
this is a we can't have a co-worker
relationship
well that's not friends I'm talking
about platonic friendship that doesn't
involve any sort of attraction or sexual
slash romantic undertones whatsoever see
it's it's my personal belief that I I
don't know if someone else maybe came
like this or came with this before me
but I've kind of taken this and run with
it so I think I think men and women
generally fall into one of four
categories one they're dating or
sleeping with one another actively
two is a man is pursuing her or is
pursuing the woman actively trying to
sleep with her but hasn't gotten there
yet
the third and I think this is where the
majority of men fall is that they are
passively pursuing so they're not going
after her and they're not asking her out
on dates they're not making all these
passive comments or they're making
comments and things like that but if she
turned around or got in the right mood
and she said hey do you wanna he'd say
yes and then the fourth
and this is when I this is the only area
that I think actually works for men and
women that are not in sort of any sort
of sexual romantic interaction as if
they've already taken that step if
they've already slept together they've
already dated or they've already had a
fling or whatever it is but even so of
all four of those categories
none of those are strictly platonic
there's always been some sort of
physical or romantic attraction slash
undertone that goes along with it
right so I'm curious as to
what about this guy he makes him your
your best friend and
why you don't think maybe he falls into
category three
we well truthfully it's not like we knew
each other in person uh at first we were
both streamers on an app and uh we got
basically put into a battle together and
everyone loved watching us together and
we followed each other and became actual
friends like oh you have this in common
you like this I like this and a bunch of
other streamers started this Meetup
planned this Meetup months later
um and we were included in this and so
we went and we he had a girlfriend but
didn't tell anyone on the streaming app
so
it's a very interesting story he hit his
girlfriend from you
if you if you want some tea I have some
it's very red flag I mean
he didn't hide it from me it was um
when you're streaming obviously as a
single man or woman you get more gifts
you make more and whatever more fans
followers this and that
um than when you are dating someone and
he the person that he was dating at the
time was also on the app but they didn't
know that no one knew that they were
dating
um and they were both invited to the
Meetup I found out because he told me
because we were all meeting up in real
life and he was like you're actually my
friend and I kind of want you to know
this
and um then whatever down the line
everyone found out
um and we continue to be friends
everyone else in the streamer house kind
of drifted apart it was very real world
everyone had their drama and whatnot
um and we stayed friends and he lives
across the country and we have flown
back and forth to see each other and
gone on vacations with each other and
all because it started as a friendship
and it continued as a friendship
especially because he had a girlfriend
so I'm not that person to be like let me
just jump in and see what I can do here
no
um so it was actually great because
speaking of dating and everything that
we were originally going to talk about
um it's really nice to have someone get
to know your personality other than just
looks and you know on that matter it's
like even if he was single before we
were friends like this man lives across
the country like that's never gonna
happen anyway so the friendship was just
normal and natural because we like
talking to each other and streaming
together and whatnot
and that's just kind of how it happened
it's it stayed that way now he's like my
brother to the point that it's like if
we were to do something I would probably
be more respectfully grossed out than I
would
being like attracted to it I'd be more
dry I don't know I think you'd be
surprised at the lengths that some men
would go for to get laid I mean guys
will wait around for decades just
looking for that chance they might live
halfway across the country and guys will
bide their time forever listen I mean
I'd love to keep this going uh I got
some other guys I want to get to I
appreciate you coming on I want to tell
you so I made this announcement so we're
moving to a more of a panel style show
in a couple of weeks we're going to have
more like a panel with some women my
co-host will be back
um I would love to have you on and dive
into this a little bit more
um it's been cool I appreciate you
jumping on and uh hope to see you soon
yeah definitely
again I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out